>> Dagen: WHAT DID CHINA KNOW
AND WHEN DID IT KNOW IT, A NEW
REPORT SHOWS THE CORONAVIRUS
OUTBREAK COULD HAVE BEEN
CONTAINED BY 95% OF THE
COMMUNIST REGIME ACTED SOONER.
SECRETARY OF STATE MIKE POMPEO
PUSHING FOR ANSWERS SAYING IF WE
DO NOT FIGURE OUT WHERE CHINA
WENT WRONG WE COULD FACE ANOTHER
CRIPPLING PANDEMIC IN THE FUTURE
AND PRESIDENT TRUMP ADDRESS THE
COVER UP EARLIER.
>> IT WOULD’VE BEEN MUCH BETTER
IF WE HAD KNOWN ABOUT THIS A
NUMBER OF MONTHS EARLIER.
IT COULD’VE BEEN CONTAINED TO
THAT ONE AREA IN CHINA WHERE IT
STARTED AND CERTAINLY THE WORLD
IS PAYING A BIG PRICE FOR WHAT
THEY DID.
>> Jesse: THE FIRST CASE OF
CORONAVIRUS SURFACED IN
MID-NOVEMBER, THAT’S FOUR MONTHS
AGO.
AND WHEN THE SCIENTISTS
IDENTIFIED THE VIRUS, THE
CHINESE GOVERNMENT TOLD THEM TO
DESTROY THE SAMPLES AND THE GANG
TO THE SCIENTISTS AND TOLD THEM
TO LIE ABOUT IT, THEN THEY ALLOW
THESE WET MARKETS WHERE THE
CONTAMINATION STARTED TO REMAIN
OPEN, TOLD THE WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION THAT IT WAS NOT
CONTAGIOUS HUMAN TO HUMAN, THEY
ALLOWED THE NEW YEAR’S
CELEBRATION IN WUHAN, 11 MILLION
PEOPLE TO GO ON, EVERYBODY
DRINKING AND EATING AND HAVING A
GREAT TIME TOGETHER AND THAT WAS
A COLOSSAL MISTAKE.
THEN THEY ALLOWED THOUSANDS OF
CHINESE CITIZENS TO FLY ALL OVER
THE COUNTRY, THE CHINESE
GOVERNMENT DRAGGED ITS FEET IN
RELEASING DATA TO THE REST OF
THE WORLD ON THIS, WHEN THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION OFFERED TO
SEND U.S. SCIENTISTS TO
>> Jesse: TO INVESTIGATE AND
HELP THEY SAID YOU’RE NOT
ALLOWED.
SO WHEN THEY SAY THE U.S.
MILITARY WERE THE ONES THAT
PLANTED THE VIRUS IN WUHAN AND
WE ARE GOING TO WITHHOLD DRUGS
FROM THE UNITED STATES DURING
THE PANDEMIC, THAT’S JUST CRAZY
AND THE FACT THAT THE PRESIDENT
BECAUSE OF THE CHINESE VIRUS, HE
JUST WANTS TO MAKE SURE THAT
THERE IS A LITTLE OF
ACCOUNTABILITY TRUTH.
>> Dana: ON?
>> Juan: JESSE, I THINK YOU’RE
MISREADING THE ROOM.
THIS IS SUPPOSED TO BE A HAPPY
SHOW TODAY.
>> Jesse: WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
THE CHINESE GOVERNMENT COVERING
THINGS UP.
THAT’S WHERE YOU’RE WRONG.
>> Juan: I KNOW WHO I ELECTED.
>> Jesse: YOU ELECTED
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> Juan: WE HAVE TIME -- WE
ARE GOING TO HAVE TIME FOR AFTER
ACTION REPORTS, I THINK IT’S
INEVITABLE, WE ARE GOING TO HAVE
A 9/11 COMMISSION-STYLE REVIEW,
WE WILL BE ABLE TO KNOW EXACTLY
WHAT HAPPENED AND WHERE THIS
CAME FROM, I THINK IT’S SO
IMPORTANT BUT I WANT TO
UNDERLINE SOMETHING YOU SAID
WHICH IS SOMETHING SENATOR RUBIO
AND OTHERS HAVE SAID, WE ARE SO
RELIANT ON THE CHINESE.
RIGHT NOW WE HAVE I BELIEVE
GOVERNOR CUOMO OF NEW YORK OVER
IN CHINA TRYING TO LOOK AT THEM
IN TERMS OF WHETHER THEY HAVE
VENTILATORS THEY CAN SELL US TO
HELP OUR HOSPITALS, WE ARE
RELIANT ON THEM IN TERMS OF OUR
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS DELIVERED IN
LARGE PART FROM CHINA, WHEN THEY
GET VENGEFUL OR ANGRY, WE HAVE
TO SOMEHOW STEP IN.
WE CAN MAKE SOME OF THESE THINGS
IN THE UNITED STATES.
>> Dagen: THAT’S ACTUALLY WHAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS TRYING TO DO
OVER THE LAST THREE YEARS,
EXTRICATE OURSELVES FROM OUR
RELIANCE ON CHINA AS A
MANUFACTURING HUB, WHAT DO YOU
SAY?
>> Greg: AS A MEMBER OF THE
MEDIA I AM ABSOLUTELY DISGUSTED
HOW WE ARE SAYING THESE NEGATIVE
THINGS ABOUT CHINA, I JUST CAN’T
BELIEVE, REALLY, THAT’S RACIST.
THIS ENTIRE SEGMENT IS RACIST
BECAUSE WE ARE POINTING OUT THE
DISEASE’S ORIGIN AND WE SHOULD
BE ASHAMED OF OURSELVES DEALING
IN FACTS, THAT’S AWFUL.
MY SUGGESTION, I AGREE WITH
JUAN.
WE NEED TO TURN OUR FOCUS AWAY
FROM BLAMING PEOPLE AND MAKE A
LIST OF THE PEOPLE WHO NEED TO
PAY AND SIX MONTHS FROM NOW WE
GO BACK AND LOOK AT THE LIST,
RIGHT NOW I WANT TO GET PEOPLE
WELL, I WANT TO FIND THE
TREATMENT AND DO ALL THE GOOD
STUFF AND SCREW THE CHINESE
GOVERNMENT, WE WILL DEAL WITH
THEM LATER.
>> Dagen: I WILL POINT OUT
THAT CHINA, WAGING A
DISINFORMATION CAMPAIGN ON
SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORMS THAT ARE
CREATED IN THE U.S. AT THEIR OWN
CITIZENS DON’T SEE BUT WE
CERTAINLY DO CERTAINLY DO.
>> Dana: I THINK WE HAVE TO
FIGHT THAT PART NOW, THE
AFTER-ACTION REPORT, WE CAN SAVE
THAT FOR LATER.
I WOULD NOT REST ON THESE
PROPAGANDA PIECES, TRY TO GET AS
MUCH INFORMATION AS POSSIBLE.
AUTHORITARIAN REGIMES, THAT’S
HOW THIS KIND OF THING HAPPENS,
YOU HAVE JOURNALISTS THERE,
CHINESE JOURNALISTS TRYING TO
RAISE THE ALARM, THEY’RE THE
ONES PUT IN JAIL, THE ONES
ROUNDED UP, THE ONES TRYING TO
USE EMOJIS AND MORSE CODE IN
ORDER TO GET AROUND THE SENSORS
BECAUSE THEY’RE WORRIED ABOUT
IT.
I THINK WE NEED A LOT MORE OF A
PUSH OF SOCIAL MEDIA INTO THAT
COUNTRY, TALK TO THE YOUNGER
PEOPLE OF CHINA BECAUSE THE
PROPAGANDA WAR IS -- THAT IS A
SERIOUS ONE AND THE ONLY WAY TO
DEAL WITH THAT IS TO HAVE A LOT
OF TRUTH AND IF WE DON’T HOLD